[Music]
alright welcome to the st. Louis endgame
lecture and we're here both with a live
audience and live online and I'm going
to talk a little bit but before I do let
me just introduce this position it's
white to move and I just want to get
your sense of what you think white
should play into me I'm gonna make it
easy I'm gonna say there's even though
there's actually loads of different
things that white can do what I'd like
to pretend is that there's only two
moves ok so we're gonna pretend that
Bishop c3 is a move and the Queen e1 is
a move so think about it just for a
second I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what I intend for the lecture but as I'm
talking you can reflect on this decision
about Bishop c3 or Queen anyone so
basically the idea I have of this
lecture came to me as a kind of Epiphany
that's been building for a long time
it's something I've noticed in the chess
world and it came from two elements that
I want to talk about first the
realization I have from teaching a lot
of different players at different skill
levels is that some people don't reach
the endgame that much and so sometimes
with these students I don't even feel
like they should necessarily focus too
much on the endgame just because they're
not even reaching them game that often
and it's a kind of interesting question
a little why isn't why aren't they
reaching the endgame you know and
there's a certain kind of player who
doesn't get to the endgame
the next thing I want to say it is
similar is the players who don't get to
the endgame very often they are usually
kind of dynamic players willing to
sacrifice willing to stir things up
wanting to stir things up quickly and so
what I've noticed is that those players
the end games that they do get are nuts
they're very imbalanced endings and they
don't necessarily often feel like a
normal position because everything's
flying everywhere with my wild
imbalances and I noticed that especially
studying with my friend Jim Josh Trudel
before he turned positional he was a
crazy man and his end games were always
pretty weird all right so now let's
return to this position and the way I'm
going to frame it is there's really two
ends of the spectrum right there's more
than two kinds of players but the two
ends in terms of how we think about the
end games is I think there's the people
who want to burn things down and there's
people who want to build right the
burners are the people who are
sacrificing and are taking risks and
they're going for it
and the people who want to build want to
play it with very small advantages okay
let me throw it out to the audience and
then maybe people online can say
something as well if you had to choose
between only two moves Queen e1 and
Bishop c3 what would you do any thoughts
Bishop's III really is going to get a
totally different flavor of game than
Queen anyone it could go maybe something
like this
Bishop c3 takes takes and rook d7 and
maybe even let's just put in the move
III for white White's position is
incredibly solid and black is going to
be pinned down for a long time because
it's very difficult to prevent these the
pawns here on b7 and C sick from being
touched fried the bishop and white is
playing with basically no no danger in
his position so if we go back and ask
ourselves what about Queen e1 Queen e1
is an entirely different flavor of game
with Queen e1 white will keep the
Queen's on and he intends to play efore
and the thing about efore that you need
to understand is then the point
d4 becomes a potential weakness and
black can build on it has happened in
the game in this particular game now to
put names on it
this is reached with I think goes at the
game nine and the 1960 World
Championship match beat game 11 thank
you I always get that mixed up between
tall and Botvinnik and in this position
by Vinick played Queen c7 was playing
for the endgame almost every game in
this match and of course tall is a
burner and gets Queen e1 right Bishop c3
totally valid as well so it's an
interesting what I'm gonna call a litmus
test to how you answered the question is
a good indication of what kind of player
you are and so
the end games that then tall got in a
lot of other players who are burners
very imbalance even sack queen
sacrifices in the end game exchange
sacrifices in the end game very few what
they would think of as piddly end games
and games where people are playing for
small stuff now to give you a sense of
what I mean by building end games I'm
gonna show just a couple positions so
this first one comes from the Kings
indium and this is a variation I played
several times myself you take on e5 and
you play Bishop g5 and this is gonna be
a long game and you are playing really
to edge out blacks pieces black is
totally fine i think the best move here
is c6 but in a case we're playing for an
endgame white is for example after say
rook e8 castles where we're just trying
to say our pieces are better placed than
blacks pieces so that's an example of a
building ending and i just want to show
a couple more here's another position
this position smith slough had several
times and we get this trade in too many
people at first glance they assume that
this position is equal and the fact that
smith love won it twice against very
strong opposition to suggest otherwise
that's interesting because what we're
talking about is a very small imbalance
which is really that our knight on d4 is
stronger than the knight on b8 that's
all it is so again another good example
of a building ending and we're just
trying to keep these this small
advantage of our knight being more
active than our
tonight let's do another one this comes
out of the Queens gambit declined I've
done this as well and you take and there
are several different ways this can go
but just imagine something like this and
again White has some very small
advantages namely that his rook is
better placed than his opponent and the
whole game from here is going to be to
try to make small improvements to our
position and trying to make one or more
of our opponent's pieces bad so another
really good example ok one more of just
I just thought I'd do a little catalog
of boring openings that I've played and
our kind of famous this comes out of
when you play like an English and black
insists on playing a Grund felton you
can get this ending and again white is
gonna say this time that his King is
going to be better on a square like c2
and the bishop on f8 is not gonna really
be happy on g7 because it's hitting a
rock on c3 so again this was again a
really good example of the building
position I'm just trying to eke out a
little bit of juice from the position to
make the opponent suffer ok now let's
consider what an end game looks like
when it's more dynamic and a little bit
more violent one example from my
personal experience is you know I start
about my friend Jim Josh Vidal and we
studied a lot together and he would
always in his actual games and in the
analysis that we do head down these
really obscure roads with fantastic
imbalances in the position and so
upstairs one of the u.s. championships I
was I played I played Joel Benjamin who
I think is a better player than me but I
I thought I needed to play like Fidel I
needed to get a very imbalance position
if I was gonna win and so I played efore
without really even preparing I just
knew the kind of game I wanted and I
don't want to cover the game in too much
detail but I just want to show you we
have incredible violence here we have
incredible violence a year everything's
hanging on the board and I think at this
point I have a very nice position but as
often happens in these situations you're
gonna what you're gonna collect is
you're going to collect something like
the exchange and black might have as in
this case some powerful center pawns and
so here is a totally different kind of
ending and it's the kind of ending that
you're gonna reach if you play vicious
attacking chess and sometimes of course
it's not going to go your way it's not
of course always gonna go your way and
you're gonna get something like this
which is you know wildly imbalanced
materially if nothing else and of course
my king is born alright so I thought
there was a lot of different end games
that I could take a look at in
particular but I wanted to look at a
particular ending and a particular
player I want to look at the Benko first
of all and I thought it'd be fun to look
at one of my old my friends john fedor
woods who was back when his game was
played one of the top u.s. players and
he was playing the Bangko all the time
now one of the funny things about the
Benko first of all is it's really like a
sister opening to the Benoni because in
the benoni you
also have less space than white and you
have to try to trade because you have
less space and you are trying to get
some drama on the queenside
before you get murdered in the center
and your king
so this Benko first of all the Banco
opening naturally wants to go to an
ending because in the ending the space
advantage that white has in the center
won't be as keenly felt and the
interesting thing though about fedora
boots is when I looked at his games
there was so much violence especially at
this time of his career that there
weren't that many actual straight-up
endings right so this is what I mean to
say at the beginning of the show the
people who are on the far end of the
burner spectrum burning spectral they
would have burned stuff down they will
there's two things about their end games
that they're gonna get they're going to
be fewer they're just going to get fewer
endings they don't they're just gonna
steer away from them and I think what's
gonna be critical to the development of
every player's I think it's fine to play
that way it's a beautiful inspiring way
to play but the trick about it is when
you is to say well I want to burn things
down but I don't want the endgame to be
such a whole such a you know lack in my
game that I'm afraid of reaching it
right so I think that's one of the key
questions for these people is they don't
actually get that many practical games
to play the endgame in so they're often
very inexperienced and don't feel the
need okay so that's the first thing I
said of course about the burners and
then of course the second thing is that
their end games will be weird kind of
like we're gonna see here
one thing we'll say clearly about the
builders is the builders you know let's
call them the boring people they
obviously need to develop a huge skill
set when it comes to end game play and
oftentimes with those slow building
positions you it's there's an intuitive
element to it but you really also need
to count and what I mean by that is not
just count like pawn moves and calculate
but really like see everything that your
opponent can do and because it's really
all about containing your opponent when
you play that way all right
so let's take a look at this this
position is totally interesting even
today and let's say that the virtue of
what White's done is he's at least at
this point refused to trade anything
right by going to g2 the bishops kind of
funny on g2 but at least there's no
imminent trade happening now for black
which is what he wants
now let's talk briefly about the the
idea of the the Banco which is really
like we're putting pressure on the a and
B really mostly to distract white from
crushing us in the center and that
honestly was something it took me
forever to understand and if you play
the Banco it's a huge advantage if you
understand that and have some experience
because your opponents will think that
their advantage consists in the a pond
that's simply not the case they're about
their advantage consists in the space
advantage in the center and at the
moment the a pond doesn't mean that much
yh3 to stop Knight g4 and Knight e5
trading stuff off alright very standard
stuff
efore ninety eight ninety five and here
already maybe the beginning of some bad
signs that black the yeah the black gets
this trade Bishop d7 is a nice move you
didn't have to do it but he is holding
on to the pin on c3 and this is very
simple banco stuff at this point we're
moving in on the queenside making grief
for black for white and e5 is a clever
move if white takes it then the pawn on
c5 will be weak and Verret let's say
fright from this point we're gonna start
to get kind of let's call it the madness
in the position Bishop c8 and one nice
thing about this move is the fact that
white has ghosted us with the bishop and
what I mean by that is just that the
bishop on a6 didn't touch anything now
the bishop is going to come back the
other way
so I don't want to spend too much time
with this I want to get to the endgame
part and we get this whole position
see 496 Queen t2 good move all right so
here we have the endgame and it's a
really interesting position the first a
lot of people I think on first glance
might think that white is better because
he has an outside passport now one thing
I often say that gets me in trouble and
I hope the st. Louis Club doesn't feel
it that I'm talking loosely here is I
say pawns aren't people and what I mean
by that is simply they're you know they
don't affect the game in the same way
the placement and activity of the pieces
do so the pawn on a2 really without any
kind of support and this happens all the
time in the bank Oh without any kind of
support it's really just just a guy left
out on the limb over there there's not
much to do to help it and I was weird to
think that black would have the
advantage your honestly because you know
it just seems that there's nothing much
right doesn't seem like there's that
much going on well let's take a look
Bishop f1 we trade some stuff and then
we play a phone now of course a lot of
these moves from both sides could be
debated but this is a very practical
kind of position and let's look at the
way this way so take stakes and the
first thing we should say is we have a
really interesting imbalance here that's
going on it's definitely in Black's
favor and that is that when you get to
the endgame
there is a huge advantage to having
connected ponds especially pawns that
can become connected passers and one way
to talk about this is to say you know at
all phases of the game there's really
three dimensions to chess right you have
a material dimensions which is just who
has more stuff and you have a time
dimension who has more 10p and then you
have this third thing which is harder to
understand which is the quality of
position and I think one of the reasons
end games are tough is it's hard to
understand what that what that quality
of position means in an end game and we
can talk about King activity and peace
activity of course but then like this
game if you have some connected passed
pawns not only will they maybe be
reaching for to become a queen but as
we'll see in this game there's also they
can also work to actually create mating
Nets against the White King something I
find again again teaching is that often
I feel people don't appreciate how much
the attack for mate in the endgame is is
that stake I feel like people are just
thinking about pawns and material and
getting their paws to the other side of
the board but the attack on the king is
very much a real thing okay rook c6
Bishop f8 it seems right that nothing
incredible has gone wrong here rook d2
and black plays f4 and Bishop b6
here's actually a funny point where when
we talk about playing this kind of end
game well there is a vast literature
that I very much enjoy of chess problems
of chess endgame problems and I don't
know quite why I enjoy them more baby
because it's they're cleaner and there
you can really do some nice calculations
and have some nice ideas in the end game
studies in any case if you're gonna be
one of the people who likes to burn down
the houses studying those kinds of
studies I think is really what you what
would really be helpful and in fact
black plays a totally reasonable move
here in f3 but he missed a great shot
which i think is to me like a endgame
study which is rook a six and it looks
silly because you don't want to play
rook takes c6 because you don't want to
help this pawn become stronger right
well the problem is and by the way that
this would work wherever the bishop went
whether went to d8 as well his rook
takes d5 really nice shot we're not
hitting both rooks and you can have one
you can have one of our rooks but he
can't have both and it's a major problem
not only because we've won the pawn but
because we're worth looking at serious
connected pass pawns here
okay so f3
and there's a simple mate threat we're
up g1 b1 hmm by the way a good rule of
thumb is that in the end game and in the
middle game in the opening it's a pretty
good idea to in general leave your pawns
on the opposite color of your Bishop and
the point is simply that your Bishop in
this case is controlling the dark
squares and your pawns can control the
light squares so it's almost the same
principle I never you put it this way
but the same principle as having the two
bishops right in the the whole thing
with the two bishops is the bishop is
just a better piece than the night
because it controls more squares but the
downside is of course that yet the poor
guy only touches half the board so if
you put your pawns on the light squares
you can fight for the other half of the
board that's not available to you
Kingi 1.e4 and I can imagine white
thinking that he was maybe okay here but
in fact it's really problematic here so
Bishop e3 check King h2 and here there's
definitely more than one move and I
wouldn't be surprised if we were in
serious time pressure here the move
Bishop g7 makes a lot of sense to me
here but okay let's look at what fed did
and I'm assuming it's just because this
was played back in the day that they got
more time and moved 40 rooks e4 and the
problem is if you don't win any of those
pawns it's kind of it's not gonna work
for you rook g1 is going to be coming
notice it's I guess it's obvious at this
point but notice that the pawn on a2
really is just a spectator the thing is
going nowhere and a lot of it has to do
with the fact that black is the one who
has the initiative here
white is trying to trade the rook on the
eight so he doesn't get made it
check going after the pawn and we get it
and you know one pawn is often not
enough to win but the problem in this
position is really that black continues
to have the initiative the pawns are all
set to be going on light squares and the
pawn on f2 is fixed and can become a
weakness and let's just say it the white
king even though we traded one pair of
rooks is still not out of danger here so
surprisingly to me I think this position
is if not lost very close to lost let's
look here D for a4 we're not really
interested in the bond because bonds
aren't people and it's funny we you know
do certain extent you'd say to yourself
well wait a second wasn't that a good
trade for white
well the bummer is though that we're
going to come after that f2 pawn and
yeah we'll see here so rook rook c6
Bishop g3 and it's actually already all
over King g1 any ideas of what black
should play actually it's ridiculous I
was doing this the other day too and and
I was I think I was I was giving a
lecture and somebody I asked a question
like that and they was somebody shut up
this is totally ridiculous we can see
what's going on a notation for your that
seeing a stupid question well it's not
the first time that I've done that yeah
Black's going Black's going downtown
here yeah mm-hmm so III and that's
pretty much the end because you can't
allow e to you can't really allow EF
either and we have rook g2 coming and
that's in fact what happened and notice
now that there's no way to stop the F
pawn from Queenie because we're gonna
check on a square like a1 and his checks
don't really do anything black takes
this time here very admirable there's
nothing white can do now we check and
this is all over I'll play a couple more
moves but basically you know you got the
pawn it's gonna be winning pretty easily
he tried some dirty tricks there we have
to give him that yeah
check the missable King and he gives
them so yeah a really interesting game
and maybe just to recap what I'm saying
and maybe Ben has any questions from the
audience I can address those the online
audience but the basic concept that I'm
putting forward here that I think is
kind of useful to categorize people is
that there's a fundamental intuition in
every chess player that goes probably to
their personality or you know how how
they grew up or if they had some drama
and their childhood we can you know
theorize but we know this from
experience most players do that they
face both kind of players and some
people are in between right there's no
strict division between people who want
to build and people who want to burn
stuff right but we definitely have all
met the burners and played against them
and we've met and played the builders so
it's a nice spectrum and the end games
that they get are nice indication of
just how different the chests that they
experience in their chests life is
entirely different from the other
people on the other side of the spectrum
it's a different skillset and honestly
for me it might be a point where you ask
yourself tell yourself ask yourself as a
player like well what is it really that
I'm good at for example I enjoy
attacking and I have won some nice
attacking sacrificial games but am I
really that good at it probably not
probably not and so you know the fact
the interesting thing about it I don't
really necessarily plan because I wasn't
aware of this distinction when I did it
but you know when a mediocre guy like me
becomes a GM it was a lot of it had to
do with choosing boring positions like
this and this and this and then you know
painfully acquiring the skillset of
playing end games because this will all
ultimately lead to very complicated
endgame positions they are they all
become very convoluted but not usually
not materially imbalanced like the
burners gift of course you can get us in
exchange exact later in this position
it's technically possible but in general
in general no it's going to be more tame
even if it's going to be violent for
example right upstairs last year's
championship garea had this position
against Fabi though I believe it
actually was the the other variation
where black it's very similar but I
believe it was like Fabi played this
variation any case it's a very similar
position and I thought garea got a great
game and then
you know the other thing about playing
like this is the games are longer when
you're a builder and that what happens
with garea fan that game was that he
fell into time trouble and Fabia's of
course you know an evil genius when it
comes to endings and creating problems
then what do we got I think that 1,800
players in particular often fall into a
trap where when they think of endings
they think of learning algorithms for
example in the diversity manual which is
a great book for what it is it's really
just teaching you endgame algorithms you
know how to checkmate with a certain
constellation or win with a certain
constellation whereas in reality what
end gameplay is at least in practical
play on how I say in reality is far
before you get to the algorithms you're
gonna get to positions like this where
you're gonna need to learn how to build
the small position you know build up the
small advantages and a great book that
helped me was Smith lofts and game
virtuoso which is basically just a
collection of his endings
and playing through you know end games
by great players who talk a little bit
about what's going on and the principles
behind them I think in general that's a
good start for an 1800 player well Ben
should we call it there do we got
another question
little bit off topic
the caro-kann you know it's gone it's
it's having a hard time let's say that
it's having a hard time
and let's go and we'll talk briefly
about Carl conscious because we have the
question what I do one reason I want to
answer the question is there are loads
of great endings in this kind of
position
Kaspar are Kasparov played black as this
honestly and Karpov played a lot of
great games as white a great end game I
really like is Karpov versus Larsen as a
double Brook ending comes out of this
position and that was how the CARICOM
was played back in the day and this
position I feel if you could get this
position all the time with the caro-kann
then that would be great
the drama with the Carl Khan now really
I think is all about this move and when
I was a kid people thought that this was
no bueno because the bishop got out and
they said to themselves something like
well we've got now a French where the
bishops out and what White has shown
over the last I don't know 20 years and
I think to my my short was the first guy
to really push the case is that actually
c5 will be difficult to play because the
light-square weakness is on the Queen
side and the loosening the opening of
the d4 square and if you don't play c5
you're gonna have less space so white
can play for a nice space advantage in
this position and so to the answer the
question I would say if you like this
position then I think that's fine but it
is going to be against a good player
anyways this is gonna be a good you're
gonna be tested know do the totally
different subject but it's also
important like end games to learn to
play with both space and lack of space
and this is a perfect example of that
kind of dynamic heading out of the
alright well let's end it there thank
you very much and we're gonna do this
we're doing this next week I think and
so if you have any questions or things
you want me to cover maybe a specific
ending you can write to me on Twitter or
you can write to the club's Twitter and
I'll try to cover it alright thank you
[Music]
you
you